[Musica]
[Applauso]
è prassi nelle aziende andare a misurare
il clima Che cos'è il clima il clima è
composto da tutte quelle percezioni e
pensieri che le persone hanno rispetto
al proprio ambiente di lavoro oggi noi
vogliamo condividere con voi vogliamo
farvi sperimentare un metodo che abbiamo
ideato in tanti anni di lavoro esatto
prima però ci piaceva l'idea di fare un
po' una fotografia di come percepite voi
il clima nella vostra azienda Alza la
mano chi lavora tra di voi un buon
segnale già questo molto bene Quindi noi
abbiamo installato una telecamera
nascosta dotata di intelligenza
artificiale che ora vi sta fotografando
Ma davvero Sì sì sì sì Sta fotografando
il vostro pensiero il vostro cervello si
chiama thinking detector Quindi ora vi
lanceremo una domanda voi dovete
rispondere solo a mente Ok
pronti Pensa ad un film che racconti il
clima del tuo ambiente di lavoro forza
forza Pens clima nel vostro ambiente di
lavoro com'è È caldo è freddo è positivo
pensate sta già rilevando e abbiamo già
il grafico ragaz dei vostri pensieri
pronti L'era glaciale al
35% un po' freddino un po' freddino
vediamo se va meglio la prossima non ci
resta che piangere il 30 quindi 65% 23
un clima un po' così peggio di così non
penso possa andare Titanic
20% ci sarà anche qualcuno di La vita è
bella 7% già già meglio Open heimer 7
Però forse vuol dire che il clima è una
bomba Magari è è positivo chi lo sa chi
lo sa Poi c'è un'altra fettina mi sembra
un 1% Ma poi c'è il buffet l'1 per avevo
un po' di fame e mi ha preso
anche Sono io sono io sì Quello del
buffet sono io sì sì sì sì Bene bene
bene Abbiamo voluto iniziare così in
modo leggero Come da nostra consuetudine
per affrontare in realtà Un tema che è
molto sentito nelle aziende Ed è proprio
come si vive come Come si respira il
clima in azienda e vogliamo condividere
con voi una una statistica un po' di
dati e informazioni ci sono tante tanti
studi in merito Oggi vogliamo
condividervi uno studio di ransta del
2023 uno studio recente che va a mappare
che cosa cercano le persone oggi negli
ambienti di lavoro ci sono varie voci le
principali sono queste due che vedete
rappresentate una il buon equilibrio tra
vita professionale vita privata la
seconda un'atmosfera di lavoro piacevole
entrambe sono collegate e correlate al
clima aziendale ma voglio soffermarvi
con voi proprio sul concetto di
atmosfera di lavoro piacevole che non
vuol dire che dobbiamo essere tutti
amici dobbiamo far feste gli ambienti di
lavoro ma questo concetto ha a che fare
con il concetto di sicurezza
psicologica la sicurezza psicologica è
quella percezione individuale che le
persone hanno rispetto al proprio
ambiente di lavoro Cioè se mi sento a
mio agio o meno a lavorare in quel
contesto senza aver timore di essere
giudicato o quantomeno o peggio ancora
di avere la il timore per la propria
carriera o per la propria immagine
facciamo degli esempi Vi è mai capitato
di andare di entrare in una riunione e
avere il timore di esprimere un'idea per
essere
giudicati oppure faccio un errore e
cerco di non comunicarlo di Non portarlo
Perché chissà che cosa succede Oppure
ancora Ho un'idea brillante ma non la
comunico Perché Perché tanto che cosa
cambia Ecco Questi sono tutti quanti
elementi che denotano una insicurezza
psicologica Ecco che ci sono vari studi
che hanno mappato questo tipo di
attività cioè per esempio uno studio
fatto da Google il progetto Aristotele
che ha evidenziato come un team
altamente performante abbia come primo
posto il concetto di sicurezza
psicologica per noi questa è diventata
proprio una missione lavorativa è quello
che facciamo tutti i giorni è cercare di
portare questo perché più nutriamo la
sicurezza psicologica più possiamo fare
in modo che le persone possano esprimere
il loro talento in ambito lavorativo
prima Stefano diceva che si fanno le
mappature di clima nelle aziende Com'è
che vengono fatte di solito e vengono
dati dei questionari delle Survey Dove
si va ad indagare alcuni aspetti ad
esempio il tuo rapporto con i colleghi
con il capo la tua soddisfazione
rispetto al tuo ruolo quello che fai Ehm
tutti questi dati vengono raccolti
appunto in maniera logica in maniera
razionale la parte di là del cervello
che vedete rappresentato Però noi ci
siamo accorti che non è sufficiente solo
questo tipo di analisi per mappare
veramente il clima dentro un'azienda
serve anche conoscere i movimenti i
comportamenti di un gruppo dal punto di
vista anche emozionale più creativo più
percettivo questa parte del cervello Sì
infatti immaginate per esempio la
capacità di ascolto o la capacità di
lavorare in team oppure la capacità di
apprendere ma anche di gestire gli
imprevisti e gli errori sono cose che tu
devi andare a mappare osservando
analizzando i comportamenti lavorando in
maniera più profonda per noi lo
strumento principale per andare a vedere
come reagisce Come si muove un gruppo da
questo punto di vista è il gioco far
giocare un gruppo di persone ti dà
tantissime informazioni che assieme a
quelle più razionali danno veramente
un'idea del clima che c'è in un'azienda
Quindi quindi direi che vi abbiamo
promesso all'inizio che vi avremmo fatto
sperimentare Quindi siete pronti a
sperimentarlo Sì sì un po' più n tu Sì
grazie perfetto molto bene Allora
vogliamo vedere Che clima c'è qui adesso
in questo preciso istante siete pronti
allora lo faremo prima eh nella modalità
Logic razionale Quindi vi faremo delle
domande voi risponderete con un numero
da 1 a qu quando vi daremo noi il via
pronti prima domanda prima domanda
valuto positiva l'esperienza vissuta
finora al tedex spiazzola sul Brent
quindi uno poco quattro al massimo chi
dice uno ripeta
uno chi dice due ripeta due
tre quattro qu bene bene bene seconda
domanda seconda riesco pensare al lavoro
e sono concentrato sui to quindi uno se
state un po' pensando al vostro lavoro
cose vostre o quattro se siete ben
concentrati chi dice uno
du 3 4 Beh buon Bu ultima attenzione a
questa domanda un po' delicata eh
considero le persone presenti in sala
particolarmente brillanti
cosa qu qu poi chi dice
uno
due Grazie È mio cugino è mio cugino
tre qu qu
Ah ecco bene abbiamo abbiamo visto già
quindi già abbiamo già una percezione
del clima positiva Sì attraverso i dati
Però come vi abbiamo detto C'è anche
l'altra parte del cervello che adesso
attiviamo siete pronti a mettervi un po'
in gioco chi sa cantare bene tra di voi
Oddio
non è importante cantare bene e tra poco
appariranno i testi di due canzoni una a
sinistra e una a destra se in questo
momento vi risuona di più quella di
sinistra canterete quella di sinistra se
vi piace di più quella di destra
canterete quella di destra tranquilli
alleniamo prima la voce Ok riscaldiamo
la voce perché tra l'altro oggi 30
settembre è il compleanno di
Stefano e quindi cantiamo insieme Tanti
auguri a Stefano Così ci riscaldiamo 1 2
3 Tanti
auguri a te tanti
auguri veloci abbiamo 12 minuti Tanti
auguri a Stefano Tanti auguri a
te Pippo sai benissimo che non è il mio
compleanno dovevamo scaldare la
voce scaldata bene Adesso viene la prova
vera e propria le due canzoni sono la
solitudine di Laura pausi e il più
grande spettacolo dopo il big bang
pensate a quale vi piace di più in
questo momento e la canteremo insieme
decidetelo
partiamo da quella eh Vi do io il via
Chi ha scelto quella partiremo Al mio
tre 1 2 3 Marco se n'è andato e non
ritorna più è il treno delle 7:30 senza
lui è un cuore di metallo
[Musica]
un applauso ragazzi che
vocina
Pro vediamo chi ha scelto il più grande
spettacolo dopo il big bang 1 2 3 Il più
grande spettacolo dopo il Big Bang il
più grande spettacolo dopo il Big
Bang io e te bella applauso anche per
loro
Beh Pippo grandi capacità canore questa
mattina a Piazzola piazzola sulbrenta
abbiamo un po' giocato ma abbiamo anche
visto come utilizzando i due sistemi
puoi rilevare un sacco di informazioni
Intanto abbiamo visto che c'è coerenza
tra l'uno e il 4 di prima clima positivo
ma anche l'energia che avete messo
adesso è estremamente buona e
estremamente dinamica quindi il fatto di
lavorare in queste due parti ci aiuta a
raccogliere un sacco di informazioni che
realmente ti danno una fotografia del
clima reale che si respira nella tua
organizzazione oltre che alleggerire il
clima perché penso che lo percepi adesso
no un un alleggerimento e meno tensione
rispetto a prima la domanda è Cosa posso
fare realmente però per cambiare il
clima e per migliorarlo nella mia
azienda
Eh la l'azione è molto semplice in
realtà ed è agire sulle tue abitudini
perché le abitudini sono le azioni che
determinano veramente Che clima c'è i
micro le micro aioni che poi noi
chiamiamo abitudini determinano il clima
in un'azienda e noi per farvi lavorare
sulle vostre abitudini vi abbiamo fatto
un piccolo dono lo trovate nella bag ed
è quello è il dado delle buone abitudini
e potete usarlo già da domani mattina
domani a domenica magari no da lunedì
nel vostro ambiente di lavoro Che cos'è
il dado delle abitudini Esatto lo potete
lo potete trovare lo potete montare ci
sono due facce c'è una parte logico
razionale e una parte creativa
percettiva come l'avete come abbiamo
sperimentato oggi nella parte logico
razionale se lo montate da questa parte
potete trovare tutta una serie di
informazioni per esempio feedback dai un
feedback positivo a un collaboratore a
un collega questa mattina tiro il dado e
mi capita smile oggi scelgo di sorridere
più del solito o Thanks oggi ringrazio
una persona che di solito questa cosa
non la faccio ma oggi dirò più spesso
Grazie quindi concludendo vogliamo
condividere con voi un'azione e
un'ispirazione
l'azione è quella di usare il dado
Quindi da lunedì provare a utilizzarlo e
vedere anche i benefici che potete
ottenere dal dall'utilizzo stesso e poi
l'ispirazione l'ispirazione è quella che
attraverso le nostre abitudini possiamo
lavorare su quei piccoli cambiamenti che
uniscono le relazioni
possiamo attraverso le abitudini questa
attenzione questa leggerezza che
portiamo possiamo portare Gioia nelle
relazioni possiamo portare eccellenza
nella prestazione possiamo abbassare i
muri relazionali lavorare sulla
sicurezza psicologica Quindi per noi è
fondamentale che attraverso le buone
abitudini coltivi nutri un buon
clima Grazie Stefano bellissima questa
chiusura Però io vorrei sperimentare una
cosa cioè Eh siccome li vedo già molto
più felici molto più sereni Secondo me
la percezione del clima nella loro
azienda è già cambiato Cioè se attiviamo
di nuovo il thinking detector Questa era
l'immagine iniziale vediamo dopo il
nostro speech com'è cambiata vogliamo
vederlo No solo il buffet 2% no eh Pippo
è perché a forza di parlare venuta fame
anche se sì Stefano Pasqualetto Filippo
borillo grazie
grazie
C